I don't want to calculate high
resolution utopia for myself,
only to have it squandered by fortune.
How do I ensure the meaning I
experienced this self determined?
Well,
you can't because there's an arbitrary
element to existence,
so it is going to be squandered to some
degree by fortune,
but that's.
That's not the point.
What are you going to do?
Just sit back on your laurels and wait
for things to roll over you,
so what you do.
Look,
the hero myth basically says,
go out there,
confront the drag and get the gold.
Share it with the community and and and
live properly,
or it says,
the alternative is faced the tyrant.
Enter the desert as a consequence
because everything falls apart.
Recast,
structure,
find the promise land.
Those are the two elements to the hero
myth and you might and that's divine.
It's the closest thing to divine that we
know.
You might say,
well,
what happens if you follow the divine
path and then so it might be,
well,
everything turns out perfectly because
God is on your side.
It's like,
no,
that isn't what happened because things
don't turn out perfectly.
It's your best bet.
It's your best strategy,
right?
That's the thing,
and you know,
dragons wouldn't be dragons if they
couldn't eat you and so,
but that's okay.
That's okay.
And this is something I found so useful
about the biblical stories,
posts especially about the abrahamic
stories which I didn't know that well
until I lectured about them last year.
You know,
God calls people to the adventure of
their lives and so you could say in
part,
God is that force within you which calls
you to the adventure of your life,
and it says,
get away from your family.
Get away from your blind and unconscious
comfort and get the hell out there in
the world.
Well,
God calls Abraham out from his father's
where he stayed far too long and from
his kin where it's secure and like the
first thing he encounters is a famine,
and then he encounters a tyranny
inhabited by people who want to steal
his wife.
It's like you think,
well,
he ever happened.
Should have just stayed in bed and
ignored God obviously.
Well,
that isn't how it is.
It's like we're built for struggle.
US human beings.
You're not after the bubbles of bliss
that does Tsq described in,
in notes from underground.
We're built to contend with the world.
We're built to contend with reality.
You want to challenge and the best way
that you can take on a challenge because
the challenge fortifies you so you don't
want to be secure.
You want to be strong and you get strong
by taking on optimal challenges and so
you lay out your destiny in the world
and you take the slings and arrows of
fate and you make yourself stronger
while you're doing so and you might fail
and fortunate might do you in,
but it's your best bet and you know
people have also people that have
extracted unbelievable successes out of
catastrophic failures and so,
and I'm not saying that in a naive way.
I know perfectly well what happens to
people.
You know you're doing fine in life and
then you get cancer and then six months
later your debt and all the heroism in
the world isn't going to save you at
that point,
but that's not the point.
That's not the point.
Life is bounded by mortality,
but that doesn't mean that you don't get
out there and content and you develop by
contending and you minimize the net
amount of suffering in the world and
that's something,
man,
that's something to do so it's,
it's it beats laying in your basement,
getting bitter and then doing the
terrible things that bitter people do so
you can't ensure that the meaning you
experienced yourself determined,
but you can play your role to the best
of your ability and that will be good
enough and that will be good enough.
That meaning the meaning that you'll
find in then in that I believe is
sufficient to be sustaining and perhaps
even sustaining through the flood.
So it isn't that you can avoid
catastrophe,
it's that you can prepare yourself to
deal with it honorably when it arrives.
That's what you've got.